[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the Daily
Mirror columnist Susie Boniface and the
columnist at the article Ali Mirage
they'll be with us from now until
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages and the front page of
the times first has the former Health
secretary Sajid Javid suggesting that
those who can afford it should pay to
see the GP to help the NHS
another fine mess on the front page of
the Daily Mirror as Rishi sunak is fined
for not wearing a seat belt in a video
that he posted online
The Daily Mail reports on claims from
the labor MP Rosie Duffield that her
party has a woman problem after she was
shouted down during a debate in the
Commons
the express warned of banks closing all
High Street branches in the near future
after Lloyd's announced today it'll shut
another 40.
The Daily Telegraph says there won't be
long queues for Brits going to Europe as
the EU delays new fingerprint scanners
the financial times leads with Google
joining the growing list of tech Giants
slashing jobs
and the Daily Star has the possible
secret for Eternal youth
and a reminder by scanning that QR code
that you see on your screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow morning's newspapers
while you watch along with us
now tonight we're joined by Susie
Boniface and Ali Mirage and there they
are Susie Ali lovely to have you both
with us good evening to you both and
let's get started with the front page of
the Daily Mirror and Susie your paper so
we'll start with you another fine Messer
reference there to Laurel and Hardy but
this is Rishi sunak getting that fine
yeah um and it's it's kind of
astonishing that we're now apparently so
blase about our Prime Ministers being
fined for breaking the law that uh there
are lots of people out there tonight
saying oh well it's not very important
is it doesn't really matter it's only a
seat belt or the rest of it
um so it's worth pointing out I think
that of the 1500 or so deaths on our
roads every single year in this country
about one in three are connected to the
fact that there is no uh there's no seat
belt on the person who's died and it is
contributed to their death and so it's a
big thing if someone in the public eye
whether that person is the prime
minister or David Beckham or the king
who's not wearing a seat belt when they
should be wearing seat belt it does
actually matter it is a big thing and
it's I'm confused and and wondering
really whether
um either Rishi sunak had his seatbelt
on and when he was doing the video took
it off and turned around not aware that
seat belts actually do 10 with you or he
was never wearing one in the first place
but I in either possibility
um makes him pretty stupid it's it's
just Daft to take his seat belt off
under any circumstances or not to put
one on uh and Ali pick up on some of
that I mean do you want to speculate on
what happened whether he took it off
never had it on was told to take it off
by the person perhaps filming the video
I think it was captured by the Allure of
Instagram and uh made a mistake and I
think he's uh fessed up to the mistake I
mean pretty difficult not to when uh you
put it out on social media and he's been
fine uh it's not helpful uh for the
Prime Minister clearly it's not been an
easy uh 24 hours he had been uh
crisscrossing the country uh to announce
uh 2.1 billion of leveling up uh Monies
to 111 different projects uh he's had a
lot of blowback from some of his own
Tory MPS about the fact that their
particular areas have not uh received
money from that pot and he's also
received criticism from the labor
opposition as well uh so it's not been
an easy
um a few hours for him but this is a
this is a mistake mistakes happen I
personally think we need to be careful
about how much we make of these things I
I take the point that it's uh unhelpful
it's not right you should be mindful if
you are in the public eye to set an
example but I don't think it's something
he did at all deliberately it was a
mistake but more fundamentally if we're
going to be this uh pedantic about
holding people in a high office uh to
standards which we sometimes ourselves
fall short of uh we can get fined for
all sorts of things reaching speed
limits and other things not that I'm
encouraging people to do that but it
does happen even inadvertently with some
of the sensitivity of speed cameras
around
um what are we supposed to do what
people are we going to have
your hands up to want to go into public
life and the quality of MPS that we've
got at the moment with the greatest
respect is not the highest that we've
had for many many years and if you've
got a situation now where potentially
everyone's going to be looking at every
single little error that you make
certain MPS are being knifed in their
surgeries or in the case of Joe Cox
being killed you get constant abuse on
social media uh people are rounding on
you think they own your life who's going
to want to go into this job so I think
it's it's unfortunate it was a mistake
uh he's accepted it I think we should
move on okay just a quick thought from
you uh Susan there because I can see you
pulling a face at some of what you heard
I think it's I think it's stretch
incredibility it's a sort of compare the
murder of Joe Cox the fact that she's
saying next having some criticism
because he didn't put his seatbelt on
um I think I think it does matter
um I I take Ali's point that you don't
want to have an absolute angel in office
and we probably couldn't find one if we
tried but I'm sure that there will also
be some in questions uh being had within
the prime minister's security detail who
of course there should have been a
police officer in the car with him and
did you or did you not see your
principal take his seatbelt off because
that is after the death of Princess
Diana I would have thought rule one that
the Metropolitan protection protection
group say you do not take your super off
in a in a speeding car all right so
let's move on to the next story early
we'll pick up with you here if we can uh
The Daily Telegraph and this one uh
another story involving the conservative
part this one has the potential to be
much more serious doesn't it the
headline in the telegraph there so how
we tax penalty could cost him job it
gives a little bit of the background we
heard Sam coach reporting on it earlier
in the program and uh where you think
this could end up
well again this is not helpful at all uh
Nadeem zahawi is the conservative party
chairman apparently this tax Arrangement
which involves some sort of offshore
vehicle in Gibraltar we're led to
believe has led to a fine uh it's he's
not been clear about how much he's been
fined but it's reported to be in the
millions uh and clearly the exchecker
sorry sorry come on
apologies Ali sorry I was I was speaking
to the gallery there you continue
yeah yeah no no so basically we don't
know how much it is exactly in terms of
but but it's reported to be in the
millions uh and clearly if you've just
uh recently served as Chancellor of the
exchequer and now your party chairman
this is not a helpful look for the party
I personally am intentionally relaxed to
quote Peter mandelson about people being
Filthy Rich uh provided they pay their
taxes if he's paying his taxes that's
fine the problem here is that he has
been fine there seems to have been some
sort of issue with this Arrangement it
regards from what we're led to believe
uh how uh shares in ugav uh the polling
company which he uh effectively has got
shares in were handled he's saying it's
a family matter it's related to his
father so it's we don't know the details
of this it is deeply unhelpful I don't
think we should resign yet unless uh
more comes out and and there's a lack of
transparency he's been fine it's uh it's
not a good look uh but I personally I
don't think there's enough at the moment
for him to be resigning unless something
more comes out in the next few days now
Susie before I come to you a spokes from
foreign said that as we've repeatedly
said Nadine's taxes are up to date and
are fully paid in the UK Mr Zari does
not recognize these numbers and he's
never sought legal advice for dealing
with
hmrcs so just pick up on some of what
Ali was saying there I mean not a great
look for the party as Ali was saying but
it's it's more serious than that isn't
it
yeah and I'll tell you what should be a
resigning offense Kamali which is that
when this story first broke a few months
ago uh Nadeem zahawi said it was smears
he said that there was absolutely no
investigation by the National Crime
agency and both of those things now turn
out to not be smears but something that
we in the trade like to call the truth
now wherever the full story is in the
background in terms of whether there's a
source I've got a family issue involved
or not
um if I didn't complete my taxes
properly
and I had to pay a 30 uplift plus
interest on the money I hadn't paid the
tax man that would be because I had done
something what we also like to call in
the trade wrong and you don't have to
pay a fine unless you've done something
wrong so here we have something where
the chairman of the toy party a former
Chancellor the exchequer for about five
minutes once
um has done something wrong with his
taxes somehow or another he's had to pay
a fine he's got to pay interest on that
fine we think it's about a total of five
million pounds on a gain of about 3.7
million
um and he not only has had that
particularly sticky issue to deal with
um he has misled the public he's misled
the public a lot he tried to shut up
journalists when they're reporting it he
tried to gag a newspaper or two
um and it's not cricket and those should
all be resigning matters because they
show someone acting no matter what the
true background may be acting with
dishonor not only to the tax them but to
the British public just final thought
from you early on this because I mean
Susie lays out there some of the the
numbers involved and and what kind of
issue do you think it raises as well
with someone that deems a highway who
was a successful businessman but perhaps
that feeling that someone paying all
that amount is a fine for in the tax
that he was meant to have paid does seem
out of touch with a regular person
yeah Kamali on the out of touch point I
just can't accept it because on that
basis a lot of MPS would be out of touch
because they weren't way over the uh the
average uh wage in the country I mean if
we're going to be in touch with everyone
we have to walk in every single person
in this country's shoes I mean that
would never be possible so I I'm
perfectly fine with people being
personally wealthy and having their own
money I think Susie raises a a valid
point about dishonor and about the fact
that certain statements were made before
which may now uh turn out not to be true
I mean this is something that mediums
are hard we should very much come clean
on and make a statement about just in
terms of Dishonor though the bar has
been set low so low by the previous
prime minister I mean there's no defense
frankly for the current situation uh
that the conservative party chairman
finds himself in but the bar has been
it's been hollowed out completely to the
extent that now what is left I mean I
really do have a worry about a the
quality of people coming into public
life and I'm glad that uh munir Amir is
a um a Boris Johnson's former ahead of
policy set up a a new thing tank called
Civic future to try and encourage people
of some stature and quality to come into
public like both in the Civil Service
and as MPS because we have got a
dishonorable system at the moment and I
think whilst majority of MPS sort of go
about their jobs to the best of their
ability it has really been hauled
through the gutter with parties and
various other issues in recent years
Patterson parties pincher I like to call
it the three p's so what is left there
is no one left in politics at the moment
unfortunately okay ali uh so we're going
to move on quickly with users we don't
have loads of time left I don't want to
bring that the story inside the times of
course we were reporting it all day this
is about that meeting at the Ramstein
Air Base in Germany and the uh the
possibility of those tanks being sent to
Ukraine you know the Brits are sending
the Challenger to some 14 but hope for
the leopards too and that's not coming
yet
no thanks thanks Germany you managed to
it up again so what's happened is
Ukraine are expecting that once the
winter mud has cleared Russia which is
on the back foot in Ukraine is going to
launch a spring offensive and it's going
to try harder now they've got the winter
perhaps to um regroup and try and get
some of their their main metal tanks
forward and Ukraine doesn't have very
many tanks the tanks it does have a
Soviet era ones and what you've got
scattered across Europe are an awful lot
of leopard tanks which were developed by
Germany uh after the war during the Cold
War and they were designed specifically
okay designed intentionally to take on
the Soviet t90s which is what Putin's
using in Ukraine at the moment
um they're quite light they don't need
an awful lot of Maintenance or not not a
huge amount by comparison to others and
so and there's a lot of them handy now
Germany has said we will only let you
have those tanks and even the countries
that they have sold them to they still
have to ask Germany's permission to pass
them on again they said you only let you
have those tanks if other countries are
also sending you tanks and they've
suggested that the U.S send the Abrams
tank now that is an absolutely massive
stonker of our high-tech machine all
right it takes 300 000 of Maintenance a
year you know uh about 10 of that the
tank Fleet is is in maintenance at any
one time it's got Electronics Optics
hydraulic stuff coming out of your ears
if you put your head in the turret at
one of those it is not suitable for what
Ukraine has to do with it at all and
they can't maintain it and even if they
could where are you gonna get the parts
from you know is Russia going to bomb
the supply planes bringing in the in the
in the spares and Equipment it's not
appropriate and so the suggestion is
that Germany is just all a bit uncertain
or we don't know if we know we don't
want to be too militaristic about it we
don't want to give Ukraine tanks in case
the war spills over into our borders
well Germany needs to wake up and smell
the coffee if Ukraine doesn't beat Putin
and then Putin's gonna come knocking on
Germany's door and that is zelenski's
point which is you need to give us the
leopard tanks and then we can beat him
you know they need a low-tech tank fight
the Soviets low-tech tanks it's as
simple as that and Germany is just
saying no because either because it's
scared or because it somehow just
doesn't want to upset Putin take your
pit yeah we'll appreciate that Susie
Ellie would love to bring you in but
Susie's done the lot for us and we've
run out of time in this section guys
thank you so much we're back with you
very soon now uh more from the papers as
I said including this on the front page
of the Daily Express all about the
future of banks
thank you
[Music]
hello there and welcome back you're
watching the Press preview uh joining us
are Susie bonifacean Ali Mirage all
right guys let's just get in to the next
couple of stories and Ali I'm going to
pick up with you a front page of the
times here we've got Sajid Javid with
some suggestions on how to alleviate
some of the pressures on the NHS and he
calls for a hard-headed conversation and
has a plan to make those who can pay to
cgps
well I think it's very interesting I
mean Sergeant Javed has done a number of
jobs uh in government he's now decided
that he's going to leave Parliament but
he was Health secretary and what he's
saying is that this National
conversation around the NHS needs to get
a lot more candid and he's calling for a
fee to be imposed for people who can
afford it uh to pay it when they see
their GP now this is a sort of
co-payment uh mechanism we've always had
this Mantra at an almost religious
fervor in the country that we would have
an NHS free at the point of use and
something that a lot of us subscribe to
but the NHS is in a dire situation right
now and that is because not only has it
had a winter crisis for every year I can
imagine and remember but also on the
back of two years of being overwhelmed
with kovid uh people are exhausted they
feel underpaid there's a massive 7.2
million waiting list backlog and you've
also got massive crisis in Social care
this has to be paid for in some way but
it's not just a question payment it's
also a question about what the NHS is
for what it does and whether it should
be reformed and it's not just Java
calling for
um
fees but also we're streating the labor
Shadow is calling for reforms in the NHS
and for a conversation an open and
honest debate about what the NHS should
be doing and what it should not be doing
and I welcome that I think it's reached
an inflection point now but we can't
continue as we are we spend above the
oecd average on the NHS but it's not
delivering for people and I think that
that is beginning to now uh sort of try
people and I think that there's a place
now for a national conversation about it
uh Susie just a quick thought from you
because as Ellie was talking there
you're shaking ahead of me I've got
loads of time but I do want you to come
back
we spend 18 below the European average
online Healthcare in this country
um and the reason that Sajid Javid is is
writing this I think it's got nothing to
do with actually what's being suggested
everybody who's had anything to then it
just knows that if you were to charge
for canceled doctor's appointments the
means testing for that in itself would
cost far more than you could possibly
scrape back most people miss an
appointment at the doctors because
they're in hospital it's as simple as
that the reason that's more interesting
here I think is why he's decided to come
forward and start saying I've got a big
idea even though it's the unworkable and
most stupid idea which everyone's
already dismissed and it's because
frankly he's positioning himself to be
leader of the Tory party after Rishi
loses in a couple of years time
he's leaving Parliament leaving
Parliament how can he do that sorry
sorry
quite right he's positioning himself to
be if he's so busy to leave why would he
come forward with a radical idea Ali he
says he's stepping down but I'm certain
that when the conservative party wants
to rebuild he will be trying to get
himself there at the front okay just
quickly on this one yeah all I'll say is
I honestly think and this is why I
welcome the labor party also Stormer and
West Street also calling for a proper
debate because it's just not functioning
the way we need it to function and if we
we need to get Beyond this sort of
Mantra that we have and be realistic and
honest about it and that's why the times
is running a a one-year review into it
we need that thank you for that Ali and
Susie just finally this quick story on
the front page of the express this is
about a High Street Bank branches
closing and uh that'll be a loss to many
people who do rely on being able to go
to their local branch
yeah I think this story's been running
repeatedly in newspapers the past few
years it feels like I've read it a lot
of times everybody knows that you need
to have access to a Banks and cash in
your local High Street and most of us
just don't have it your local Corner
Shop may have a you know a cash machine
that you have to pay to access your
money from and therefore lots of people
don't get to use it it shuts people off
and it also means that small local
businesses have to use Visa transactions
which they have to pay a fee for so you
know food is better for them Susie Ali
do appreciate that lovely debate thank
you both guys and more from you later we
hope all right let's take a look at what
the weather hasn't done